welcome to gke Essentials where we
explore Basics and useful tips for
getting up and running with gke
I'm kazlyn Fields a developer advocate
here at Google Cloud where I focus on
Google kubernetes engine and open source
kubernetes kubernetes is designed to
enable and manage apps at scale but
Beyond The Upfront challenge of running
applications lies something on
everyone's Minds security
today we're going to talk about how gke
integrates opinionated security tools to
help you keep your systems more secure
assistant
[Music]
the concepts we're going to talk about
today fall under the umbrella of GK
security posture management
security posture is a broad term that
covers many security aspects of your
system it's critical that you understand
and actively manage the security posture
of your gke clusters to help you do this
we provide managed opinionated tooling
one of the main tools that we have is
the new gke security posture management
dashboard
this dashboard is built into the Google
Cloud console and consolidates several
tools layers and perspectives that
relate to your gke system security
in the dashboard you'll notice a variety
of information about the security
posture of your clusters and workloads
the charts give you a quick look at
security across your clusters including
things like the severity of security
concerns across your clusters the types
of security concerns and What proportion
of your clusters and workloads are
affected the gke security posture
dashboard gives you opinionated
kubernetes security built into gke
it provides best practice actionable
security guidance
the dashboard shows you results from
multiple monitoring analysis and
scanning technologies that are built
into gke
the dashboard provides visibility so you
can understand your overall security
posture at a glance and these tools in
the dashboard are all included with GK
the idea of these tools is to help
simplify some of the challenges of
kubernetes security
security is a constant so these tools
provide continuous scanning and
assessment of your workload security
over time
in addition to Gathering insights about
your current security posture Google
also provides actionable remediation
advice and guidance
by the way even though we're focusing on
gke here the dashboard and GK itself
integrate with the broader Google Cloud
security ecosystem the tools Under the
Umbrella of GK security posture
management perform a variety of
activities to assess Monitor and manage
your security posture
this includes scanning container images
for known vulnerabilities from multiple
sources
when we find vulnerabilities we also
provide opinionated guidance around the
severity of the vulnerability and steps
that you can take to fix the issue
and it's not only vulnerabilities that
we can Surface and provide
recommendations on to avoid security
issues due to misconfiguration we can
validate your workload manifest against
industry standards
if we find potential concerns the
dashboard shows you remediation steps
and advice
that all sounds like a lot to take in
but how GK security posture management
works can be broken down into these
three steps
observations are gathered from Source
data from workloads and clusters
analyzed settings images configurations
and usage patterns
the data from these observed factors is
assessed using numerous detection
sources to find security concerns
once assessed gke Services concerns via
tools like the security posture
dashboard alongside actionable
recommendations the gke security posture
dashboard is just one component of the
Google Cloud container security
ecosystem for example binary
authorization provides deploy time
security controls that ensure only
trusted container images are deployed
onto gke
gke security posture secures clusters
and workloads through detailed
assessments actionable remediation
advice and insights
software delivery Shield improves
security posture at scale automating
build and artifact provenance enforcing
stlc policies from a central control
plane and the security Command Center
provides a broader view with cloud-wide
evaluation of security and data attack
surface providing asset inventory and
Discovery and identifying
misconfigurations vulnerabilities and
threats
all of these tools are part of how
Google Cloud helps you better secure
your GK clusters and workloads in this
video you learned about a variety of
ways Google Cloud's ecosystem of
security tools helps you manage the
security posture of your gke clusters
while these tools cover a wide area of
security considerations the GK security
posture management dashboard can help
you better understand your kubernetes
security posture at a glance with the
concepts discussed in this video we're
confident you'll be on your way to
building a gke cluster that suits your
needs you can get started with gke by
visiting the Google Cloud console and
checking out the links below and stay
tuned for our next videos where we dive
deeper into gke topics foreign
[Music]